it's been over a week since we covered a
scary video so now it's time to do
13 of the creepiest craigslist ads from
a channel who i haven't covered in a
while he's been killing it on the
youtube still
mr effin nightmare if you guys haven't
subscribed to this guy's channel do it
as soon as you can
craigslist boy do i have some
experiences over there been a while
since i used their service
so let's see some of the creepiest ads
they got to offer seriously subscribe to
mr nightmare he's one of the best
volume two we missed the first one
this was an eye-catching post made in
2014
though it was eye-catching for the wrong
reason the advertiser states that he's
seeking an unpaid young houseboy that
will care for him
but he had to note that he meant in a
non-sexual way
he also notes that he's a 55 year old
male who lives alone with his cat
but even if that isn't slightly
concerning considering he's seeking
younger males to live with him
he claims to have had three house boys
before this could leave one to wonder
whatever became of them
they definitely didn't die they're
definitely not dead this man's picture
mirrors something straight out of a
serial killer playbook
these kinds of ads are the very likely
ones to be leading to something far
worse than would appear on the surface
this was the listing for a bed frame
that a subscriber named rich sent to me
and actually responded to
firstly right off the bat the ad looks a
little sketchy sure
starting off with the poor grammar and
misspellings yes the poster claims that
he's not storing the bed frame in his
house anymore
but rather only available storefront
why also where is this storefront what
does it look like
if these weren't red flags enough
lauderhill the town in which this ad was
posted
has an extremely high rate of crime rich
explained in his email to me that he
comes from a very poor background
and even though he saw the red flags in
his post he was willing to drive over to
the location he received after texting
the number on the ad
drove to the location at 10 30 pm which
turned out to be a closed down looking
thrift store
he stepped out of the car with the
engine still running oh my god dude
straight for the bushes next to the
storefront where he could easily see two
men hiding
he got back in his car and drove away
yeah
damn man good that's a close call good
use of eyeballs this is an incredibly
creepy craigslist post of the man
looking to stop an all-female band
specifically consisting of women aged 18
to 21.
oh god just assumed by the looks of the
ad and the man himself friendly
considered typing 16 or 17 instead of
18.
the ad calls for young girls who aren't
afraid of older rocker dudes telling
them what to do
oh god man what a terrible call
the guitars and ants can really draw
your attention away from the gross
messy bookshelf and bottle collection i
hope no one fell for this [ __ ]
my god some reason thought it was a good
idea to capture his bandage
i hope no one fell for this apparently
predatory craigslist
yeah jeez i really hope no one fell for
that crap i
really do too craigslist called miss
connections this section is home to
personal advertisements which arrive
after two people meet but are too shy or
otherwise unable to exchange contact
details
like everywhere else on the website
weird things are posted in this section
such as this ad the ad was posted by an
anonymous man who seemed to be stalking
a young boy
he said in the ad we've met on several
occasions
but i've seen you i like to wear that
met's hat a lot does no one report
these like daddy's hit me up the post
actually included two photos of the boy
on candid camera
one in the grocery store and one outside
in a seemingly wooded area
wow to be no older than 14. very public
yeah it was taken down creeps out there
my god oh this ad was posted in january
of 2014 in australia during a major heat
wave
temperatures were reaching up to 114
degrees fahrenheit in certain regions
so this ad probably seemed like nothing
short of a miracle at first glance
the ad offered free ice cream to anyone
in the area claiming they were doing it
out of christian courtesy
nice the ice cream truck would be parked
in a location that would only be
disclosed to people who contacted the
poster
nice yesterday
and was told to meet up at a certain
parking lot outside of king's park
okay the boy and his brother who
answered the ad who said they arrived
partially just to see if it was legit or
not
did find the ice cream truck in the
parking lot but
two police cars were also parked
alongside it it turned out the ice cream
truck was stolen
the refrigerators in the ice cream cream
was melted
creepy creepy
oh it wasn't disturbing in the same
sense of the others on this list it's
just creepy
this was an ad posted by a 26 year old
asking for a female roommate
who he would wave the red feet for only
if they were willing to create some kind
of romantic religion
that this was a guy proud of his
openness of his intentions
it's likely he may have wanted more than
just a relationship
possibly some more immediate services
there's a lot of these definitely
offering free housing for young women
for relationships or
open minds in return must be sexy and
open-minded
in july of 2015 the fbi arrested
39-year-old nathan bryant
allegedly trying to solicit children for
sex by advertising his babysitting
services on craigslist
federal investigators suspected that
brian to gain access to kids
though this wasn't enough to prove that
he was guilty of anything
so the fbi posed as a father who was
offering their child for sex on
craigslist
that's when they were contacted by brian
warranting his arrest
this was one of brian's many craigslist
postings where he advertised his
babysitting services
it may not seem too bad on its own but
knowing who was behind this listing is
what makes it truly horrifying
and that yeah could have been created by
someone with completely matched
intentions
dude why would you ever want to mail the
babysitter
he was above the age of 21 who responded
to an ad he placed on craigslist for a
non-existence
this guy's from a different century he's
also convicted of the attempted murder
of scott davis
a man who answered the craigslist dead
was then shot in the arm while escaping
from beasley
this is the only screenshot that could
be found from the specific ad that he
posted
the ad said wanted caretaker for farm
simply watch over a 700 acre patch of
hilly farmland
you get 300 a week and a nice
two-bedroom trailer that isn't a
battlefield
holder and single preferred but we'll
consider all terms
you must have a clean record and must be
trustworthy a drifter preferred position
the farm is used mainly as a hunting
preserve is overrun with game
has a stocked three acre pond but some
beef cattle will be kept
nearest neighbor is a mile away the
place is secluded and beautiful
it will be a real getaway for the right
person job of a lifetime if you are
ready to relocate please contact
asap position will not stay open
three out of ten men who answered this
ad were shot dead by richard
wow this is another misconnection damn
these are buildings this list is
deliberate
the poster stalker rather has the young
girls address
you even posted a picture of the 14 year
old girl's house
in the post he wrote dear sarah you
don't know me yet but i've been watching
you these past two weeks
you are a beautiful girl who needs to be
taught certain things and i could teach
you those things
to give you all the money you could want
oh and much
[Music]
thank god oh jesus i was never able to
find more details
such as if the family was made aware of
this or if the poster was found
or even if it was just some kind of how
horrifying ugh
this ad was posted on june 10th 2014
under the free stuff section it
advertised a free couch in good
condition that would be put out on the
curb around 10 p.m
in a normal neighborhood this would seem
like a lucky find yeah however this head
was posted in one of the worst areas of
detroit
and one of the most difficult
would not be looking to give a couch
away rather looking to make any penny
possible off of it
this was a screenshot taken of the ad by
someone who came across
it there's no way of knowing if someone
actually fell victim to this
but this ad just had too many red flags
about it
most likely a group of people waiting
for a naive victim to rob or harm
like the bed frame listing mentioned
earlier in this video
this craigslist post was noticed the
murderer was voting about his first
killing to the people of tulsa oklahoma
it said i wanted to thank tulsa for
letting me have my first kill
it all started here so i was thinking it
should also be my first
i was nervous as hell but i will get
over it it was a stranger on stranger
kill
so the police will have a difficult time
it will not be my last though
thinking about going to oklahoma city
for the next
this wasn't the only end of its time to
pop there was a second one that i could
not find the screenshot for
which apparently showed a picture of the
victim's body and the poster gloating
over his second killing
took place in stillwater oklahoma and
while i didn't mention a link to the
first post
it seemed like too much of a coincidence
[Music]
oh man this is a rather strange young
man looking for a roommate
visitors to the ad would be greeted by
this picture which looks like something
taken from a horror movie awful shot
likely would not take this ad very
seriously and would never dream of
taking this guy
never touch the shower curtains closed
you come get some of the rules and
aggressive writing
do not like people staying up late you
may have a friend over but if they speak
too much they must leave
i like peace and quiet no indian
visitors
native american or or easter
east there's two others never take the
bags off my windows better yet don't
step into my
this ad room legit let's hope this guy
never found her that's an album cover
this last dad was very open about its
posters intentions
it's titled cannibal no way
can not be real blurred images that
would give you a good idea of what
exactly was going on to the victims
the ad said i'm going to be very open
about my intentions
i am accountable and i'm looking for a
willing victim he even uses the word
victim
if it has been your dream to donate your
body as food oh my god
i will not be tortured that is crazy
that is crazy generosity with somebody
else
oh my i can't believe this
that damn i thought these were all going
to be from like the men's
seeking women like that section i
thought it was all the personals all the
all those all that was going to be from
yeah casual encounters yeah
i did not think it was going to actually
be like
whoa oh wow that was surprising this was
an experience
this is one of those videos where i was
like okay if this is all from like the
hookups creepy section i'm not sure if
we'll put this on youtube
no no
weirdest sales advertisement sections
that delivered mr nightmare he did it
again with a wonderful narration great
editing
mr nightmare kills it all right so i
guess you can break the sound of some
categories you got like roommates
services job opportunities free [ __ ]
miss connections and then proud killers
what category should we talk about first
oh i mean we gotta build up just like
the list did why don't we start with the
missed connections just because that's
like the craigslist stereotype
yeah and and the let's get the icky
stuff out of the way first because both
of these were about people being like
you don't know me but i know you and i
here's a bunch of details to prove that
let's meet up i don't care that you're
underage
that's number 10 and number five the man
stalking the boy taking a photo of it
and that man
and the man stalking the young girl
honestly some of these not in this
specific category but some of these are
like
laughable in the sense of just i can't
believe someone would try to get away
with this
there's ways you can trace this back and
try if this gets
really dangerous or out of hand you
could easily be caught some people do
fall victim to these things now i've
never fallen victim to anything like
this but when i was younger
i have agreed to respond to like some
really
bad craigslist ads in the past that have
really screwed me over
in so many ways so as much as i like
sometimes will laugh when i'm watching
this i'll also think like oh but when i
was younger i've definitely made some
stupid decisions with craigslist
you know like that time you tried to
join the all-girl punk band
yeah i've never done a craigslist
opportunity but i feel like something in
that sphere would be
the most likely to get me it's like
these guys want to be caught the miss
connections ones with the stalkers and
just publicly putting it out there it's
like they want them to know
you know like i don't know there's like
some weird rush or rise they're getting
from it some weird
sick sadistic high or whatever i
don't know there's a criminal profiling
psychology aspect to this
it just doesn't seem like there's any
self-awareness of going like what if i
was a stranger reading this would this
come across
creepy this is their way of getting it
out of their system the services and job
opportunities ones
that's where i think people can follow
the easiest to being a victim of these
kind of things
yeah yeah i've fallen for it many times
actually postmates the first time i got
a postmates job is when it was a
craigslist ad that was before postmates
became what postmates is today so that
was one of the few legit ones
guys go to craigslist to find yourself a
job during covington
you could still make it work for you the
one with the punk band like from our
perspective you you see that
and i don't need like the mr nightmare
creepy music and everything have i just
thought
don't trust this guy but there are
people especially young girls who would
be probably vulnerable to such
such a thing you know especially when
you're looking for an opportunity
or something even with like the
babysitter one
oh god like that one's really creepy
very creepy it's just if
you're a guy above the age of 21 i would
never just ever ask you to babysit
i just immediately my mind just goes
probably at pervert that's where my mind
just goes
every time i mean you don't even see
that many male house sitters but yeah
like an adult
male babysitter who's like my services
are great and i prefer to do
overnight shifts yeah again even if
you're trying to sell yourself as a
professional these people don't seem to
have any suspicion radar
it's weird enough it's like the ones
with the services and job opportunities
categories are the ones where the guys
have been
actually caught like the groundskeeper
murderer that was fascinating i love how
his like his pitch sounded good yeah i
admit it like that
actually sounds like a really relaxing
gig out of the middle of nowhere he's
got to feed some cows
leave a relaxing quiet life get paid 300
a week
the second that ad got to the part where
it's like it's all just game animals on
this land i was like you're trying to
hunt people
aren't you and then sure enough i feel
like whoever
this guy was is probably living out
there trying to do his most dangerous
game fanfic or larping experience well
they show the photo of the victims
and they all kind of looked a little
similar in appearance
which is not unusual and not strange
it's just interesting to see like
the kind of ad that type of person was
attracted to you know what i mean
yeah and then of course you got like the
roommates one
which those that doesn't surprise me
i've seen a lot of
you know you hang out with your friends
and you go across like the casual
encounter section to see what like weird
shits on craigslist yeah
or you know you're just an individual
looking for a hookup you know whatever
you do things when you're 18.
and don't be ashamed of it like me okay
so it's number 13 number eight and
number two with the house boy
well like i got house boys i've had many
house boys before not creepy at
like too much emphasis on it man you got
too much emphasis if you want to learn
some little kids and this is way too
much emphasis
but then i'm like how did you get the
other three house boys if that is legit
and what boys are hanging out on
craigslist being like man i need to go
serve a person i need to get a gig
housekeeping for an older guy
poor kids who need some work you know i
started working when i was like 13 years
old he did promise a private suite and
the angle of if you want to get away
from your parents
like the number eight one at the 26 year
old asking for roommates for a free
relationship that is the least
surprising one on this list to me
yeah i've seen so many kinds of like
especially on
on the like the sexual side of
craigslist who ask for these weird
ads all the time yeah that's not it's
creepy it's still
creepy that doesn't negate the
creepiness i'm just saying that's the
least surprising one to me i don't know
who falls for this but
i'm i have to imagine that he's playing
some weird law of averages here one out
of a thousand someone's bound to
you know that's the thing him and the
punk band guy i have to imagine that
they're just going i'm just gonna state
mice my you know the way this needs to
be and someone out there will be okay
with it and
someone will probably have the type of
personality where they maybe
want someone to dominate them in some
way shape or form
exactly you know there's something out
there man there's something out there's
someone out there who's willing to say
yes
and then you got like the number two one
with the strict rules
and i'm not gonna lie as weird and
creepy as it is i thought it was
predominantly just
really funny yeah yeah yeah it's so
ridiculous
i wouldn't be surprised if that was just
someone
pulling some weird trolling pranks on
craigslist pretty well
it is just so insane someone found like
an abandoned house in the woods
took a couple pictures and put up an ass
and if you're willing
to be that roommate you're insane
you've earned everything you've brought
your way by because there is
no masking in that ad don't take the
trash bags off my windows
yeah don't have guests who want to talk
at all no indian people okay
just like this is the most overtly
insensitive ad and you know all the
other creepers are trying to come across
like they're not
creepy yeah even to a certain extent the
ones with the misconnects are trying to
come across like they're not creepy when
they are
yeah this guy ain't covering anything if
you agree to that
you're you're you're completely at fault
here's my creeper ass lifestyle and you
got to be a hundred percent okay with
that and the 250 dollar room is yours
that's what i thought was so funny about
that is because i'm like well whoever
fell prey to this that's their that's
their problem
you know well there's there's a theme i
think of overcompensation because like
in the free [ __ ]
like in those ads especially with like
the ice cream truck
where they're like we're christian we're
super christian and we're motivated out
of our christianity
and i was sitting there reading that
going you seem like you're trying to
hide an ill intent
yeah most of them are and like it was
weird how the free bed frame wanted the
free couch there's two
very common things here one is like yeah
free furniture item the other one is
after 10 p.m both say after 10 p.m on
that
the sad part is someone could easily
fall prey to this because
a lot of that is very real a lot that's
true a lot of a lot of people put
out free items all the time on
craigslist you can go and pick it up
i've done it before and i wasn't
like assaulted in any degree right you
know i've been murdered yeah
so i can't i'm just saying like it's
pretty easy to fall for that i do think
it's important that you you got to check
the neighborhood and then
after 10 pm part it's the most like the
most darkest time of day
well and yeah come to the back of my for
like all these excuses for why you can't
put this thing
in a normal environment at a normal time
of day like come to my abandoned thrift
store you gotta be wise man
yeah and then the proud killers one is
like some mine hunter david fincher kind
of crap you know
the tulsa murderer chilling and the fact
that the oklahoma stuff popped up after
that
yep yep the one with the cannibal one
now i've
heard about this stuff from like dark
web discussions yeah
of people who are cannibals and then
some people offer up their you know
their services
i've heard this this version of a story
many times
carnivore fantasies are real cannibal
fantasies
someone who wants to die and is willing
to like sacrifice their body to give it
up to
like when sometimes it's spiritual
religious related and it's creepy
what makes it creepy is it's just so
[ __ ] craigslist
i said dark web this is craigslist what
makes it creepy isn't it it's craigslist
a and b it's one of the most
mind-breaking propositions on here
because if you're lazy fair about it
it's a transaction that if these two
people are consenting and they want to
cannibalism is illegal i believe i don't
know maybe somebody out there really
wants this
and this ad could go through 100
cannibalism is illegal you know i mean i
would assume but you know some laws are
just so
out there that it takes the first time
to really
address it in legalese but i'm sure
there's you know we've already had
famous cannibals
all right guys well mr nightmare you
knocked it off this list which one
creeped you out the most
if you liked our reaction hit the like
button if you like mr
nightmare's video hit the like button
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we got a new youtube
video up keep recommending some fun
creepy videos for us to react to
because we enjoy these as sadistic as it
is for us
you guys enjoy them too last but not
least
lance door now lance my friend i know
you're getting married
okay with a wedding coming up and how
expensive that's gonna be
and maybe having more children along the
way things are gonna get pricey
now a lot of people will go to
craigslist and try to save some money
you're in law enforcement now you're not
a policeman
you're a firefighter i'm asking you dude
wherever you go for any craigslist
opportunities to save yourself some
money so you can keep providing for your
family
bring your axe with you yeah everywhere
you go
have it on hand bring your fire truck
with you the whole truck have it with
you on
hand connect to a hydrant just in case
make sure every meeting is
by a hydrant yeah okay i'm trying to
give you some advice
to take precautions here bring a
dalmatian with you because dogs are good
at finding suspicious people
you canadians are way too trusting and
lance
get a gun yeah man
you can never be too sad he's cracked in
the streets
you